hi everyone this is unit leg hammer
bringing you the highlights from the
world rapid championship magnus carlsen
finished in fifth place which was
reasonably good considering that he had
lost the first two rounds of the
tournament in fact in the last round he
played Hikaru Nakamura and if he had
managed to win that game he would have
qualified to a playoff for first place
the winner was
danila dubov congratulations it was
revealed today that Daniel was actually
a member of Team Carlson during Magnus
World Championship match against Khurana
so if not minus one then at least a
member of his team Dead Eye I wanted to
highlight this game Magnus played
against the grigory operon I was taken
aback by the simplicity with which
Magnus managed to defeat a very good
opponent with the black pieces here
Magnus played d4 and it's aimed at this
bishop on b2 and trying to block it out
of the game white played pretty
creatively with before he's offering
Magnus to take upon but if black does do
that then white will have pressure
towards the pawn in the center so I
think Mullen is this reaction here was
exemplary
he played Queen d6 he only cares about
having these black pawns defending each
other and thereby keeping the bishop out
of play white played rook c1 increasing
the pressure and Magnus once again he
doesn't care about winning upon he plays
97 he understands that the important
thing here is keeping these pawns in a
line keeping them protecting each other
and keeping the white bishop
out of play and at this stage of parents
started spending a lot of time and he
wasn't really sure what to do next and
mungus just developed a crushing
position by playing ricky 7 and then on
the next move rook e8 the position is
all about these two guys on the e-file
putting pressure down the board and the
white bishop is not really doing
anything so it was a good strategy to
keep White's bishop on b2 out of play
and then using pressure along the e file
to win the game